good morning gamers surprise surprise
another minecraft episode that's right
everyone what what is it complete its a
giant meatball complete no it's not
fully done yet but once the giant
meatball is finally rebuilt there will
be no more suffering and pain in this
world isn't that right year again so
ends this hey what are you doing under
my property get out
well that's so weird they just disappear
well I didn't do anything he hacked your
brain look at this dude just staring
into the blank walk hey ed hey smell
that oh hey Sven how you doing we got
stuff to do today
come on gamer let's go where my boys at
where my gamer boys at I got to show you
guys something really really epic that I
didn't realize until last episode all
right boy get in get it god damn it all
right boy get in this is oh wait do I
have a spray one I do okay swen wait up
spend please go
it's so crazy on the minecart nothing
can stop it hey you what I do people
keep commenting how Sven has survived
like five six creeper explosions all it
there's another creeper just wait here
buddy I gotta show the bros or was it ah
yeah here we go so I got where is it
this one and I was like oh that's not
that good but as you can see it has
fortune 3 on it so now when I dime a
mine
diamond it drops to two diamonds almost
every time spent come here you have to
see this why did no one tell me this I
mean you did tell me dude we're gonna be
rich spend we're gonna say okay
sometimes it drops one but most of the
time it drops - this is crazy
look - look - look sad but rich look 19
diamonds out of that okay okay oh dude
we could start a diamond business hey
can you sell diamonds in Minecraft all
right Sven get in I said get in
I said get in that I say not to get in
or did I say get it no runs what ah
Sven dice series is over remember gamers
remember today we have a very very very
important mission that's why I got all
these diamonds that complete we stay
here gamers stay here I can't believe
I'm rich I am look at this look at this
dude
look at this dude alright I can't
officially not even stack them like this
what do I want to make I'm fully
enchanted right what do I want I don't
know what to make I got everything I
want I got this weird little baby he
doesn't
it doesn't do anything stupid baby you
know so then I'm not gonna lie I Loki
kind of Miss having water sheep around I
know it's it's good that he's gone but I
do miss that
what smack what is this woodland
Explorer man water she must have left it
here but do you think it is fun maybe
what if she was trying to tell us
something maybe water sheep wasn't bad
after all maybe what the Sheep try to
help us spend what do you think I think
we have to explore this water she I mean
span
all right let's Incheon turbo because
we're going on a woodland mansion raid
one of the toughest raids in the
videogame history that has ever gained
this is gonna be our most dangerous
mission that we have Everett where's the
air game where's your game hello
where's the air again cause you're gonna
be in kidnap did I forget him how could
I forget you're again wait
where the Frick is Jurgen what the
uragan just leave what
juergen wouldn't just leave without
saying goodbye what IKEA tower you were
supposed to look after him did I leave
him without a leash he's got a freaking
diamond armor I will see him if I see
him you're against Merrigan uragan smell
again
he must be here somewhere he has to be
here somewhere
maybe he just glitched out again again
I'll find them Sven where is Jurgen
there was helicopters in this game
that'd be helpful at least are you
kidding
where is he I can't lose another year
again oh my gosh what happened here here
have you guys seen your again I'm using
your again answer me
oh no I can't do this anymore
my poor Swedish are what their sheep
must have taken it's the only way it's
the only way possible Spain
we're gonna find that raid their house
and we're gonna get back your again if
it's the last thing I'll ever do do we
need to head south and east let's
freakin go gamers what the Sheep will
pay for this looks like we need a boat I
can't believe your guns gone it makes me
so sad it must have been ok it can only
be I cannot think of any other reason
than water sheep I will follow this map
and I will find when I mean your again
sorry it's me I don't think I've been
here before we're entering new territory
Sven I'm a little scared I'm not gonna
lie
wait what is this oh gosh I'm finding
new things whole new world out there
spend you just have to look I was
literally just a rosebush and a creeper
we stay away from those and the
Slenderman and a boat on top of water
that's it super rare hello Slenderman
Slenderman more like you dead man Oh God
sorry I need your I I don't think that's
too much to ask
oh then I guess I know lame all right
stay here spend I explore boat whoa it's
a massive aah never seen one this Bay
then this is epic whoa tnt curse of
binding what is that there look we're
here to find carrots for Sven another
treasure map guess I'll take it but what
is any treasures with that you're again
smirking dude how many three treasures
whoa whoa whoa whoa jungle planks what
this jungles in fort night all sheeps
must die their canoes near water kill
him so then I know it ain't much but
we're gonna have to set camp here for
tonight
we got a long journey ahead all right
let's keep going Sven gosh how far is
this whoa there's a castle over there
I've literally never been this far away
from home spend we'll get back uragan
don't worry we'll find him wow this city
looks strangely familiar Sven isn't that
weird - a view okay maybe I have been
this far - Abu van has been in this
place before whoa it's another fortress
Oh they spotted us and sit
I come in peace I come in peace God okay
so then you sit tight papa Pierce is
just gonna run in and grab all their
epic gamer oh my god I didn't even do
anything
they are so hostile can you leave me and
stand alone
hello hello fellow gamers I'm just here
for the gaming loop enchanted cook
looting three at least at least have
something good guy oh jeez let's bounce
man have you seen uragan that's what I
thought well we're not getting closer
are we spend only we had Garrigan to
ride on my god Sven I can barely see
you're so cute
in the grass whoa look it's a white year
again whoa so pretty white your games
guide us the way white Jergens damn I
wish I could bring you guys home you
guys are pretty right Sven
do you eat potatoes fine then jeez
simple no will do come on Stan let's go
well this is like a little Hut over
there
son will be going down soon
maybe we can seek refuge here Sven
hello fail fellow minecraft the ends are
you rich or are you oh oh oh this is we
we can use this and you're not cracked
Sables we need to find one
alright let's sleep in here span woke up
outside okay whoa this is the first time
I see a jungle in mine crime this is
kind of getting more detorri than I
expected
Oh God whoa this is thick dude oh my
gosh what is this cocoa beans we can
make chocolate Sven
why do you no one tell me there's
chocolate in Minecraft look at this
place alright we can head south between
here but only on the edge of course you
haven't seen Jurgen have you Jesus
this is so far another power I spent oh
gosh you know the drill garbage come on
let's bounce man these people are poor
it's been oh he literally grew into the
grass
oh my god we're entering a swamp now
we're gonna see the whole world gosh
back off chickens don't go near Sven
all rendering The Woodlands of course of
course there's sheeps here here we are
this must have been where I found
youthspan remember I found you in the
woods
that's right Sven I did find you in
lost sheep they're everywhere you gotta
be careful here there's holes to spend
do not fall down the holes gosh we're so
far away from home spent our young
health eating
need you strong is it possible that I
misinterpreted the map Oh watch out for
those fun this is that we've been
walking a very very long time and
another village my god no oh god oh god
Sven leave we are leaving now we are
leaving now Sven we are leaving now ASAP
ASAP that ice it is gone that's it it's
gonna burn spending to go let's go let's
go let's go I'm now doing that I am NOT
doing that we are sleeping in the woods
tonight under the stars may God when
you're far away from home and your
Jurgen he is gone mm-hmm and you only
have your spin spare he is your biggest
fan see see what that Frick is that
mountains snow mountains I never been to
snow before have you ever seen snow
before Sven all right cool where we
apparently
this is so far it's getting dark Sven
day 3
good night gamers another city another
Yahoo kid this is a big one
you guys don't happen to know where damn
money
you guys don't happen to know where the
woodland mansions are do you I'd be real
helpful god they're so porcelain it's
like not even worth my time
could this place be the forest oh cool a
wildfire that's awesome starting to feel
I get trolled by water sheep well we got
other your guns here Spence I mean maybe
there's a spinet or something maybe you
can find the girl oh ok ok then I
think's minute likes you Jesus how much
food do you need God some dogs not able
to tame like a keep giving him food all
my food for that matter
holy moly macaroni Patroni this is far a
legs are killing me Sven I am actually
exhausting I can't even think what your
little footsies are feeling now I just
like misinterpreted the map or something
and I'm walking in the wrong direction
and I don't even know I'm supposed to
walk south right southeast I look more
Spence you're not getting my food only
Sven gets the food he deserves food okay
what well I wasn't expecting this Sven I
know you're scared of war I know you're
scared of water at the last time but you
have to trust me
look Sven it's the iceberg
and I never thought we'd see them
together
Oh God I just met him dying here would
just be the worst thing ever possible I
am so so far away whoa look he's angry
[Music]
look it's Evo's evil Sven
oh he's good Sven now oh my god they're
helping us what
there's alpacas Wild Ones I never seen
them in the wild before look they live
in little cage sign
[Music]
look there's Fergana Mountain Oh My gods
it's snow it's snow Sven
we're gonna have to cross these
mountains and it's gonna have to cross
another mountain it's minecraft infinite
and I'm could technically walk for
infinite amount of time question mark
please say no I need a shovel porous
vents little footsies must get taught
cold in the it's not wearing shoes he's
not wearing prod that like I am god this
mountain sucks mounts van the rest
[Music]
okay we keep going gamer all my god
things I do for epically hello earth to
Sven don't scare me like that
be careful here Sven one wrong step
careful Sven a lung there's tiny fence
oh my god they're so cute tiny Sven's
thinking how I got to walk all the way
back as well
hey look it's better than Athens bath
water in Minecraft we're doing this oh
my gosh oh wow
it's really making it lag when it's a
lot of fire geesh okay we're safe oh my
god oh my god that is so cute sign oh my
god it's got a little kid but it's oh my
god
I never see I didn't even know there was
foxes in damn alright we keep on walking
we made it at last what's meant No be
careful I spent two hours I spent two
hours walking I'm so done okay then I'll
go this way and I'll try and find the
rope so you can climb up don't worry
I'll be right back well there's a guy
right there
Oh
[Music]
get him Sven whoo all right these guys
are strong smack good job thanks for the
backup stop doing that please I need you
on your best behavior
not again it's not again come here thank
you
I need your your best behavior possible
this is extremely dangerous in here we
travel extremely far I gotta be quiet
we gotta be stealthy where do you go
that's too stealthy god I'm actually
scared all right let's take it nice and
that's a creeper in there
sit sit boy sit let me take care of
creeper you tanked enough creepers in
your days double creeper whoa it's a
face of them why would they build a face
of themselves dummies let's read look at
this oh god more creepers fighting it's
a trap okay oh god you're a creeper tank
I'll give you their G belieber look
look at this event look at this dude
I got statues of themselves that is so
dumb
now we're obviously here for their Luke
and nothing else I didn't travel all the
way across the guy frickin Lincoln lamp
I hear them they're close to lock the
word oh there's a guy there's a guy sits
in alright it's okay it's the case when
don't worry I know how to fight these
got him
oh he's rich - Sven he's reached two men
Oh another one another one we're not
gonna lose
okay bucket so they do it so like you
can't this is a prison what is this
hello oh my god that creep this prison
cell for cream pricks first in here then
nothing what's in here then no a wall I
want to get jailed in okay let's go
spent more prison cells what kind of
place is this
do you think they kept Jurgen here my
god Jurgen must be so scared in one of
these yeah this place is surprisingly
not that bad so far but I feel oh my god
what what was that
freaking teleporter at miss Fang you're
the one that's supposed to teleport this
place is cool but keep hearing them but
I don't write my crazy
there must be upset there must be
upstairs vent
we're only on the first floor we gotta
find the stairs well what kind of they
got put our first chest Wow actually you
know this might be cool because then we
can plant them in our little meatballs
it's when are you okay when I know stop
cringing please I never get upstairs so
I just dig my way out
get him Sven that's right Sven get up
that's my boy that's my boy right there
okay we have all these ladders right
don't mind if I do
gamer girls I might regret this spend if
this doesn't work oh god ooh hoo that
was close
oh god damn that's my boy that's my boy
right there I'm gonna ask you to sit now
hello
coast is clear Sven okay wait here okay
then what I have like dining room lame
where's the epic gamer look what is this
wobble alright we're gonna do some range
we're gonna do some range here oh god
there's so many headshot oh I got one
he doesn't know where I am idiots
dummies that was one more all right
stealth kills it is baby tota Nova have
died on baby I got the baby
I can dual wield babies can you Frick
off this place is awesome I mean it took
a god-awful time to get here but look at
that Sven that's awesome oh sit sit sit
he doesn't want to sit it's just lagging
sometimes don't think so oh god this is
it game over
Oh God stay there swing stay there oh
[Music]
okay arrows is the way to go gamers
another baby
we got another baby Sven this is awesome
Oh yo yo yo yo sit sit sit
Romero's died alive enough
oh yeah oh oh it's fine spend I'm don't
think so gamer they just come out of
nowhere with their frickin axis
stay there spend don't worry I know what
I'm doing three hits they're gone like
my schlong okay
good joke Felix oh yeah get him spend
yeah teamwork yeah oh that was awesome
Sven I'm so glad I brought you even
though Oh what no I'm not freaking me
that I'm not freaking with that what is
happening okay they're dying I don't
know why I'll take it yes Scott them
spend it safe we got another baby
we got another baby damn I'm out of a
diversity well this works hey guys how
are you doing
idiots spent no no we don't talk to
these guys where's the gamer Lou oh wow
we're out on the roof now but Cooper's
hiding here huh all eras perfect Jesus
so we're actually on top
[Music]
whoa oh my god what are the odds
nice okay all right all right all right
music disc what we can play records then
[Music]
what else is hiding in the floor don't
think so gamer I give me your child whoa
what is we did it Sven
come on let's escape from here we have
to jumps oh my god
Sven careful we have a long way home
span we have a long way home I was
hoping Sven I mean I was hoping your
game would be back
[Music]
when we came back Sven but at least we
have a lot of gamer loot this one goes
out for all the uragan out there thank
you for watching another episode of
minecraft many more adventure awaits us
will they find uragan in the next
episode or are they gonna have to get
Jurgen 3 is IKEA power and this is IKEA
power still gonna shine so bright in the
sky and what is with that ominous giant
meatball
who knows what do you think spend only
minecraft God not stars thank you for
watching and see you guys tomorrow bye
bye smash like ohh
a way to stand okay
moo-cow you hear this all right
we also have a new merch checkout link
in the description spend merch
juergen merch you name it merch damn
this is fire huh moo cow let me drink it
kitty
ya know nah all right bye
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]